notre séquence ping pong ce soir je
reçois anémone pour parler du film
d'alain saloum
c'est pas moi dans lequel elle joue
c'était là un peu en mode fashion n'a
comme ça des quelques principales
céréales alors on va dire la
distribution de ses produits
michel muller anémone et lucie laurier
roy dupuis c'est lui je vous le
conseille c'est un formidable acteur et
il est beau très bon acteur
bonsoir avait même on va parler de ce
film parce que je crois qu'il vous tient
à coeur et que la réaction à l'égard de
ce film nous le retrait un petit peu
annonce a meurtri pas du tout mais ça
mais ça me stupéfie c'est à dire que moi
j'ai beaucoup aimé le scénario j'ai
trouvé que le film était très réussie
c'est une c'est une comédie policière on
rigole beaucoup
ça c'est un film que sans prétention qui
est familiale vraiment c c'est une super
bonne soirée quoi là alors on va dire
qu'avec les réactions violent disney
alors on va parler des réactions j'ai
beaucoup de mal avant d'abord dire ce
qu'on va voir comme philippe riat un
prétexte à un petit voyou qui qui vole
une oeuvre d'art mais qu'on laquelle il
avait 250 mille dollars
et bien évidemment il ne s'est pas la
revente pour rien et les gens qui
veulent la récupérer dont vous qui est
carlo dans le dans le film lui font
quelques misères et il se passe quelque
chose qui explique le titre c'est pas
moi c'est qu'il ressemble trait pour
trait un policier en vacances et va se
faire enrôler lui le petit le petit
voleur dans la police ce qui va créer
tout un tas de situations cocasses mais
je vous propose de regarder la bande
annonce comme ça on aura une idée de
l'ambiance et surtout écoutez bien la
langue
quoi moi du west company 2 tu compris et
à ses joueuses de doigts vincent
papineau je préfère une petite mise au
point que ou qu'ils pensent que lui mais
pour celle de réfléchi jamais assez on
s'est lancé dans l'économie
ilike on a tout simplement j'ai trouvé
ni abonnement ria stop au lait à toutes
sortes et à patch comme une carte de
crédit
il téléphonait pas plus en attendait
hier personnes qui vont croire que
claude lanzmann est un état d'ébriété
monsieur madame l' agence pour moi c'est
long
le tabernacle la haute volta bernard
mais pas par moi je t'en es pauvre con
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a en a entendu celle de l'an
passé il faut le dire tout de suite il
est présenté comme le premier film
français traduire en sous-titré en
francophones parce qu'il ya un vrai
travail sur la langue du français il ya
du québécois il ya du haïtien il ya du
créole haïtien ya des lagons ne parle
sûrs france voilà le départ ou à
larrivée parleront des gens ne
comprennent pas toujours quoi ces salles
est amusant ça fait un gros gros succès
au québec alors le dire oui c'est alors
c'est pour ça qu'on a déjà en dvd c'est
qu'il a déjà fait sa carrière au québec
158 d'entre eux face à auxerre états
unis donc on peut dès maintenant se
faire une idée en dvd il a gagné un prix
aux états unis
dans un festival qui est un peu
l'équivalent de 10 pas de bêtises
genre un peu la quinzaine à cannes comme
ça et là il avait gagné le prix du
public
alors on va vous appuyez sur les petits
dont on va écouter la critique de xavier
leherpeur allons-y alors dit bonsoir
c'est toujours un peu délicat de ne pas
aimer un film dans lequel joue une
comédienne que l'on aime beaucoup mais
la règle du jeu étant celle de la
critique je vais donc effectivement être
net et vous avouer ma grande déception
je ne suis pas fan du tout ils gagnent
chez dans lequel vous jouez qui
s'appelle ce n'est pas moi une comédie
québécoise alors on est d'autant plus
déçu que le point départ je le trouve
extrêmement savourer particulièrement
originale l'idée de mettre face à face
trois personnes qui parlent français
en tout cas dit fait du français et qui
ne se comprennent pas alors de ce
postulat de départ on aimerait qu'il
devienne vraiment le moteur de la
comédie tonnerre qui créent des
quiproquos qu'il crée des mots oui c'est
vrai ça aurait pu être et à l'asthme
aulas est en effet à notre film mais là
c'est pas l'ambition l'ambition c'est de
faire un divertissement bien cadre d'une
comédie policière
et ça c'est en quelque sorte le le petit
plus le petit plus que de temps en temps
il mais qu'est ce qu'il a dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya devant nous donc
c'est qu'il ya une espèce de couleurs et
de saveurs aux films bons mais ils
attendaient manifestement un autre film
mais c'est très original tu m'as ce
travail sur la langue plupart j'ai
l'impression que le chassé-croisé n'a
comédie policière où le méchant est le
sosie du policier on a déjà 100 foyers
mais vous avez vu ça vous déjà jamais
annonce à ce jeu je trouve que le
scénario est original et qu'on a tenté
plusieurs fois et les critiques disent
ah oui là il est le sosie du policier on
a déjà vu ça se voit je n'ai jamais vu
nulle part personnellement aucune
originalité aucune recherche j'allais
dire pour essayer voilà de réinventer à
tout
ce procédé deuxième chose la mise en
scène là il n'y est pour rien bien
évidemment non mais là je suis d'accord
avec lui puisqu'il faut savoir que vous
sépariez aux états unis entre ennahdha
aussi le metteur en scène et iceman est
en vérité le l'auteur c'est le
producteur donc le mec il se couvre donc
c'est un set un mercenaire le
mettre en scène c'est pas le service
d'une vision c c se couvrir le plus
possible après le conducteur les
produits tueur peut changer de
réalisateur en cours de film s'en
foutent ils font pas la différence est
donc effectivement non la mise en scène
aller 2 2 c'est pas la paille a pas la
patte d'un auteur ça je sais je le
concède mais il me semble que ce soient
les chasser coin croire le jeu dit
croire dans la comédie qui prouve à elle
est efficace et même la cacophonie
puisque ces trois personnes ne se
comprennent pas il faut que ce soit mis
en scène avec une rigueur au millimètre
près or malheureusement fait pas du tout
bleu pas d'accord je trouve que ça
fonctionne en soi parce qu'il ya un bon
scénario il ya une histoire qui tourne
qui court bien et que drogue dupuis est
un acteur extraordinaire et corrige veut
dire on se marre quand il ya plein de
situations formidable et que moi je
trouve qu'on s'en fiche un peu que ce
soit pas effectivement sellini car
j'allais dire quasi aléatoire à présent
que la caméra est en roue libre en
pilote automatique que vous passez assez
fou parce que d'ailleurs même le plan de
tournage montre que les choses étaient
très très programmée que effectivement
quand le réalisateur ou le producteur
parle du film on sent que tout le projet
était dès le début établi et qui a pas
eu d'improvisation comme on voudrait le
dire c'est une sorte de roue libre et
qu'il ya un plan de travail très très
sonore il ya le mec qui secoue rythme
très lent très chiant mais c'est pas non
c'est pas la roue libre ces bâtiments
tommy de deux collèges de soin apporté à
la diction découpage qui permettrait
vraiment à la diction dit non au
contraire je parle quand même
policière avec des poursuites donc il
faudrait que le rythme soit l'auteur
évidemment d'être assis c'est un film
très enlevé l'union du film or le rythme
est quand même très inégal entre
précipitations bah oui mais parce que si
cela aussi ça court tout de suite très
vite n'y a pas de rythme le rythme c'est
précisément des râleurs 17 daudet
accelerando ce sera la réponse c'est la
définition même du rythme un peu loin
pour étirer j'allais dire moi je ne sais
pas emmerdé une seule seconde
mon fils est sain avec une banane grande
comme ça parce que l'on pourrait dire
que moi c'est mon âge que je rêve
coucher un peu ralenti mon fils kaka 27
ans avait été non seulement
oui non non c'est pas grave on s'amuse
ou samuel ça on peut pas dire ne trouve
pas vraiment le rythme qui lui serait
adéquat autre point la direction
d'acteur il faudrait peut-être que le
metteur en scène et ça n'existe pas la
direction d'acteurs vous avez des bons
des mauvais acteur d'acteurs et de
textes intelligents mais on ne dirige
pas un acteur et on ne dirige parole du
puy on ne dirige pas moins entretenir
plus à coeur de saisir toutes les
nuances des valeurs a ajouté que peuvent
représenter les comédiens or le problème
c'est que c'est comme la mise en scène
vous êtes un tout petit pont tous au
même niveau
j'allais dire en roue libre ce qui est
un peu meilleure mais en tout cas y'a
pas un soin pour essayer comme ça de
trouver dans l'oeil du puy a lieu
l'équivalent des césars pour ce rôle le
meilleur lecteur je veux dire c'est une
vraie performance à 15 heures jeux qui
sont assez différents quelque chose qui
permettrait encore le aussi de créer
cette cacophonie
alors la question genre évidemment c'est
quand est ce que vous allez revenir à
l'écran dans des comédies ou d'enrichir
le trajet puisque vous êtes capable de
faire les deux en tout cas nombre avec
des personnages qui sont à la hauteur de
votre talent qui n'est pas petit il faut
bien le dire
côté ses chronos c'est ce qu'on appelle
une chronique amoureuse
alors bon déjà répondre à la question
de critiques est-ce que anémone reçoit
beaucoup de propositions non beaucoup
nous sommes un peuple c'est à dire moi
je suis je sortis du star si ce n'est
lorsque vous lui alors à partir du
moment où
on
on est plus bas on est dans une autre de
notre économie que la recette serra et
là c'est évident que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et financièrement et est ce
que c'est vrai car les prêts pour avoir
une visibilité
je me permets de vous poser une question
est ce que c'est vrai qu'après ce
l'incident des césars vous avez été
blacklisté c'était parce qu'il ya une
campagne de calomnies quator kestrel
pour faire comme ça pour nous tous
rangés
on veut nuire et gay ça continue
aujourd'hui encore j'en crois que les
gens doutent je me serais pas vous avez
raconté attend gens qui me connaissent
pas et à qui on dit avec hideki et qui
disent ah non non on peut pas travailler
avec elle est ingérable et ceci sous la
pluie parce qu'ils sont gays ou qui
passent outre
non ils ne comprennent pas d'où vient le
bruit quoi bon en tout cas nous louerons
on souhaite le je partage complètement à
vis des habits leurs pendants envie de
vous voir de revoir de vous voir encore
je vous le dis voilà en tout cas voilà
on parlait ce soir de c'est pas moi le
film d'alain saloum avec roy dupuis
anémone michel muller on a oublié de
parler de michel muller dans son rôle de
psychopathe à l'accent à marseillais qui
est un lanceur de couteaux bien faisons
et lucie laurier
voilà un élément que je veux vous
remercier mercian prêt à bientôt à café
picouly quand vous voulez merci beaucoup
c'est un gentil l'a jamais mais j'ai
perdu des lunettes transparentes alors
il faut que je me fasse refaire
[Musique]